good afternoon everyone my name is
researcher Miller and the SCP were going
to be studying today is SCP 1936 object
class Euclid special containment
procedures SCP 1936 is to be contained
behind a 2 meter electric fence which is
to be patrolled by security elements the
area contained is roughly circular 1
kilometer in diameter security cameras
are to be installed to cover areas not
currently being patrolled expeditions
into SCP 1936 are to be escorted by an
armed element as specified by area 37 s
Security Director personnel are not to
enter spatially anomalous locations
without specific authorization with the
conditions of such authorisation
dependent on recent anomalous activity
within scp-1933 7 is to be set up on the
outskirts of the town to support these
operations and to provide facilities for
the initial testing and classification
of objects recovered from SCP 1936 once
classified these objects are to be sent
to the appropriate site for long-term
storage and study dead biological
samples recovered from SCP 1936 are to
be kept under strict quarantine and
taken to area 37 summary incineration
may be performed if the samples are
deemed hazardous in the event that any
live biological samples are found in SCP
1936
investigating personnel are to remove
themselves from the area and mobile task
forces a 229 mad Mountaineers are to be
sent in to recover and bring it into
containment
description SCP 1936 is the New England
town of Dale port in the year 1997 the
town fell victim to what is presumed to
be a highly destructive event or series
of highly destructive events over the
course of several days during this time
the foundation was unable to enter the
town or observe any event that occurred
therein due to the presence of SCP 1936
- one a gaseous area centered on Dale
port that covered the whole town for
further information see attempt at
expedition 1936 this anomaly is no
longer present at SCP 1936 having
dissipated a week and a half after its
appearance dimensions of the remaining
buildings have become significantly
altered from the original plans and a
large number of them have become
topographically inconsistent
investigations reports spatial anomalies
including rooms that become smaller when
they are entered eventually preventing
the occupants from moving doors that
lead to several points at different
times of the day and corridors that
despite leading to only one location
also lead to several different locations
no survivors from the anomalous events
which affected Dale port have been found
within the town proper but the remains
of a large number of Dale port citizens
have been recovered
cause of death varies but it appears
that a large number committed suicide in
many cases the remains of these citizens
demonstrate anomalous properties
presumed to be a result of the anomalous
event some of these remains have
included a smear of entrails and viscera
capable of picking up audio radio
transmissions from up to six miles away
sound is created through vibration of
tissues subject was found with a small
plant that gave it a small constant
flame
a torso embedded in a wall slight
movement of the torso was visible when
investigating personnel spoke blood
continuously manifests 15 centimeters
above the torso the body of an older
male with both eyes gouged out a steady
stream of ashes pours from the body's
eye sockets nose mouth and ears without
any apparent source several human
corpses discovered in a row on the Main
Street flesh skin and bone had been
removed from a circular portion of their
foreheads skin and brain tissue
surrounding the wound had undergone
severe charring at 7:42 p.m. each day
several floating torsos manifest outside
the Johnson public library simulating
the motions of running heading Southwest
along Market Road three minutes after
manifesting the torsos attempt to leave
the road and fade out the body of a
young female that floats steadily
upwards when subject to any applied
force regardless of the forces direction
this is attempted expedition log 1936
due to the unknown status of Dale ports
residents manned and unmanned
expeditions were made into a CP 1936 -
one to determine the safety of entering
as CP 1936 - one ascertain the nature of
SCP 1936 - one and its effect and to
facilitate possible recovery of
civilians these expeditions took place
over the course of several days as
resources arrived on location
attempted expedition log 1936 - one
unmanned ground expedition procedure
following the detainment of relevant
witnesses and the establishment a
containment perimeter an unmanned ground
vehicle ugv - one was sent in to SCP
1936 - one UGV - one was equipped with
atmospheric sampling sensors closed and
open circuit biological samples
including several Rattus norvegicus
brown rat instances video and audio
recording equipment were also included
results ugv - one found SCP 1936 - one
to be composed of sulfur nitrogen and
carbon oxides the concentration was
found to be at a level where irritation
occurs but would not present a lethal
hazard biological samples were
unaffected in any anomalous manner video
recording showed a smooth wasteland like
landscape starting in a hundred meters
into SCP 1936 - one and extending up to
two kilometers from the edge of SCP 1936
- one at this range radio communication
with the ugv - one became degraded and
egv - one was returned to the SCP 1936 -
ones perimeter tented expedition log
1936 - two
manned ground expedition procedure to
class DS D 512 and D 513 were sent into
SCP 1936 - one aboard ug v2 u GV - 2 was
equipped with a higher wattage radio
transceiver than that of ug 1 D 512 and
D 513 more level a gas tight hazmat
protective clothing and bio telemetry
sensors during the expedition results D
512 and D 513 were initially taken 1
kilometer from a CP 1936 - ones boundary
D 513 was ordered to D suit D 513 have
been previously briefed on this and
compiled promptly
d 5:13 reported no ill effects from
exposure to SCP 1936 - one medical
telemetry showed D 5:13 had slight
difficulty of breathing similar to
breathing smog D 5:12 and D 5:13
continually reported flat featureless
terrain while in SCP 1936 - one
unacceptable levels of radio
interference began at 3 kilometers from
SCP 1936 - one's boundary and ugv - -
was returned to SCP 1936 - one's edge
medical examinations performed upon the
return of D 5 12 and D 13 showed that
they had not been abnormally affected
during the expedition attempted
expedition log 1936 - three armed men
ground expedition this is a recording
but the forward is as follows the
following audio log is a recording of an
attempted expedition by mechanized
infantry platoon kilo the platoon was
assigned six piranha laugh five vehicles
designated alpha through Foxtrot with
mounted environmental analysis equipment
log begins three kilometers into SCP
1936 at this point two-way communication
with the expedition team was lost but C
and C only able to receive messages
sounds of a firefight and wildly varying
descriptions of the attacking forces are
heard after approximately 30 minutes the
following message is received
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
this log also has a closing statement
unmanned observations continue to
operate but were unable to reach the
town of Dale port no manned expeditions
were sent in to SCP 1936 - one prior to
its dissipation recovered materials 1936
a large number of documents were
retrieved from SCP 1936 these are
assumed to have been written by the
town's previous inhabitants document
recovered from laptop and a residence in
the southeastern quadrant of SCP 1936
dear diary today mr. stickies arm came
out of the closet instead of the window
it was even longer than ever but it was
still smoky when I touched it so my hand
hurts sad face I told mr. sticky I
didn't want any of his gross food today
and he got mad he said it was vital to
the incubation of the Lava I'm really
hungry so I ate the gross food even
though it was green and squirming
I don't like mr. sticky that much that
was obviously written by a child the
following phrase was found in multiple
locations predominantly in public
toilets and stitched into the internal
organs of mutated Dale Porte residence
I'm sorry that I could not save you from
Pangloss document recovered from a store
in the southwestern quadrant of SCP 1936
running out of canned fruit but I guess
that's the least of my worries there was
some more god-awful screaming and [ __ ]
out there tonight screaming started off
human think it was Lily from next door
don't know what it sounded like by the
end never heard anything that sounded
like that thought I heard something
trying to get in a while ago it was
Reverend harsh or walking past my window
again still ranting about God knows what
managed to get a glimpse of him through
the window wished I hadn't he had too
many spaces in him gotta leave I think
one of the big guys is coming this way
I can hear drums outside I am the voice
and the voice is me security cameras and
other video devices continue to acquire
footage while SCP 1936 - one was present
video recovered from a ruined gas
station surveillance camera on the
outskirts of SCP 1936 start time is 9:30
9 p.m.
the cashier the establishment is having
a customer a plastic bag the window next
to the two individuals smashes an
unknown organism enters through the
broken window its appearance is unclear
as its center is surrounded by multiple
tentacle-like appendages it is roughly
the same height as an adult human the
customer attempts to flee the organism
lashes out at the customer by the
tentacle the customer is decapitated and
due to the impact of the tentacle the
head is propelled off-camera
the cashier hides behind the counter but
the organism moves itself over the
counter and out of sight presumably
having landed on them blood and viscera
consistently splatter on the wall above
the counter for the next 30 seconds what
appears to be an elderly human wearing a
bowler hat and waistcoat enters the
establishment the footage becomes mildly
distorted when the individual enters the
shot and increases greatly when it
becomes apparent that instead of a face
the individual has a triangle branded
onto their skin the first organism moves
back on to the counter appearing to be
wary of the individual the distortion of
the footage increases as several
multi-jointed appendages burst from
various points on the individuals body
the first organism and the individual
engage in hostilities the organism
appears to be in a large degree of pain
when touched by the individual and
attempts to retreat out of the storm the
individual throws the organism out of
the store through a wall creating a
large hole in it the ceiling has seen
bulging downwards when the footage ends
Vidia recovered from security cameras
outside the Johnson Public Library
facing Market Street start time is 7:40
p.m. a speeding car is seen entering
frame from left traveling along Main
Street the driver appears to lose
control of the vehicle and crashes into
a lamppost outside the library as the
lamppost is broken it splits and buckles
as a partially translucent spectral
entity emerges from within the lamppost
the car's occupants leave the vehicle
and begin running Southwest along the
street away from the entity the entity
gives chase floating through the air
this goes on for several minutes with
the entity gaining little ground
eventually the Anthony stops giving
chase and undergoes several changes in
coloration a blue colored shock wave of
unknown composition is then released
from the entity and travels after the
fleeing people the shock wave passes
over the people as they attempt to turn
off the road which causes the people to
become transparent and fade
the following footage was pieced
together from partially surviving
sources centered around the entrance to
the Town Hall the exterior Town Hall is
shown having sustained damage with the
roof in a partial state of collapse
the front doors to the building are
missing replaced with a circular
phenomena glowing the blue violet end of
the spectrum a convoy of vehicles
appears travelling towards Town Hall at
speed
the convoy consists of dozens of
civilian cars and trucks as well as
foundation vehicles matching those sent
on the manned exploration of SCP 1936 -
one a small number of Humana form
robotic entities armed with the firearms
of unknown make and manufacture are seen
running alongside the vehicles as the
vehicles approach the town hall the
civilians and foundation personnel
disembark the civilians move towards the
circular phenomenon at the apparent
urging of the robotic entities and
foundation personnel a try radially
symmetric organism approximately 3
metres tall and covered in various
technological items is seen exiting the
lead foundation vehicle the organism
interacts with one of the devices and
appears to undergo a series of
controlled convulsions for several
seconds as the first civilians reach the
circular phenomenon a fractal shaped
sheet of modal skin jumps from the roof
of the hall towards the crowd due to its
low mass and high drag this takes
several seconds during which the robots
and foundation personnel opened fire on
the skin sheet doing little damage as
the sheet reaches the ground it leaps
towards the nearest civilian and wraps
itself around the civilians head the try
radially symmetric organism runs towards
the two rips the skin sheet off the
civilian throws it to the ground and
activates a flamethrower severely
charring the skin sheet and rendering it
non ambulatory the organism then
indicates to several nearby stunned
civilians to enter the circular
phenomena
do so causing them to disappear from
view the robotic entities and foundation
personnel allow all civilians to enter
before collapsing inside the circular
phenomenon themselves when only the
radial organism remains it burns the
phrase Pangloss grants you sanctuary
into the stonework above the town halls
entrance the circular phenomenon remains
in place as the organism leaves the
manifest station at area 37 of 94 live
civilians and of almost all of the
missing foundation personnel in the
weeks following SCP 1936 - ones
disappearance is believed to be related
to the above events individuals
recovered so far have suffered memory
loss regarding the events in delporte
leading to no new information being
gathered during the debrief while
analyzing recovered documents to
determine the cause of SCP 1936 - ones
arrival numerous references were made to
a cult named the victory Society the
following note was discovered in the
jacket pocket of her covered body the
head and left arm of the corpse had
swollen to three times the regular size
the corpse is believed to be that of
James Curtis who was a member of a local
religious organization known as the
victory Society what we need to trout a
bottle of milk virginal blood in
brackets where am I even meant to get
that to be mixed with the milk also in
brackets he who walks beneath dreams is
into that sort of thing apparently
assorted souls willingly sold and in
brackets alliteration is a big deal for
that which waits inside the horizon at
least 200 beetles lots of ice and then
brackets if ha Shore thinks I'm doing
the sculpture for this shivering mist
thingy he's got another thing coming two
dead bodies have to have been dead for
at least a year some human eyes the
blind ones meant to have thousands of
sockets I don't think a few eyes are
going to do it for him but oh well
Markey and Dan are getting the rest of
the stuff Laura - I think ha Shore just
sits at home with his books though the
[ __ ] the following passage was written
on the inside cover of a chart book
outside the church at the center of Dale
Porte the border of the mural is
encompassed by civil sir the Shivering
mist that will descend upon the world
during the time of awakening the mist is
all-encompassing and shall act as a
barrier to those wishing to stop the
awakening as well as confine the Great
Trinity of potential Victor's the three
at the center of the mural are the great
victor of flames the great victor of
frost and the great victor of the storm
they rain down destruction upon one
another with their true names inscribed
in unreadable unknowable rooms around
the three are visions of the great
battle that contained the majority of
those that shall come to this realm with
the juror the dark god of lampposts the
blind one illuminating the way for his
followers who leave tributes upon
crooked light posts digital manifests as
the Flies pouring out of the mouths of
his beloved and be cursed to assist in
the conflict any way he can while Nene
the trip an ER frees his followers from
the skulls of their oppressors
the shredded cabbage of misfortune will
destroy those who oppose their vegetable
monarchy Zin Herald of mark
commands the army of Lepidoptera to
carry those away who sleep with the
flowers beneath the silver ash in the
dream attics of an anime tum' the voice
of Ages though not visible is
omnipresent represented by the yellow
runes bearing his name hidden throughout
the mural finally at the bottom those
minor minions and deities pledge their
allegiance to the three victors those
who pledge their allegiance to the great
victor of flames are tinted orange great
victor of frost violet and the great
victor of storms green many such as he
who walks beneath dreams his face Sameer
triangle remain unaligned and are
painted in black for they are opposed to
no one and he had opposed to all the
dark dear de max is shown around the
edges forever excluded by the rest
sheogorath remains ruling his kingdom of
two faces before he himself brings its
downfall only to be stopped by a great
prisoner of the Dragon King 20 goats
stuck together making a goat ball spin
around and round all the way to go to
hell the skeletons forever fight their
final war the conflicts of these minor
deities will have little impact on who
the great victor of this battle shall be
several documents were recovered from
what is believed to be the body of
Reverend Michael Haj or the leader of
the religious organization the victory
society the body showed extreme
spatially anomalous properties it was
incinerated after recovery and analysis
it appears that these pages were removed
from a journal or diary but their
original source has not yet been found
July 22nd I am returning to Dale port
Godfrey wish me luck as I left but I
know he hoped for my failure he is too
idealistic to believe in my cause I took
all the necessary books out of the
library before I left though I suppose I
could have just waited until I got home
but I'm not sure if I'd be able to find
a proper way there and I very much doubt
gone free would assist me hard to get
all the books around had some trouble
with the lost wonderer dishonest odds
7th toll but the container my contact
gave me helped with the heat worries
burnt my hand handling the thing but
still you can't hope to do something
like this without minor sacrifices
James is meeting me at the station but
he'll most likely be late he always is
you have to work with what you got
but it's disheartening that there aren't
some more respectable people interested
in this venture I worry about the next
time
August first I'm a little shaken up the
priming ritual for the one of broken
nines needed blood sacrifice
I had hoped anesthetic could be used but
the ritual didn't allow for that child
is dead now and it is done
we can't lose track of the goal the
child would thank me that can be from
the bottom of his heart if he knew why
we were doing this it's for the good of
everybody it's for the good of everybody
it's for the good of everybody the
victor shall walk from the rubbles of
man and restore clarity to those who
remain I'm beginning to doubt James's
devotion to our cause August 13th the
voice of Ages needed the blood of a
heretic I suppose it just means heretic
in general the voice wasn't picky about
what kind of religion James who was not
eager to contribute but the fact that
his blood worked proved that my
suspicions were correct the liar he
would have doomed us all in his
selfishness things do not get easier but
my time is coming to an end I have
decided that we will not operate over
the next two days it will be a time for
rest so we can prepare for what is to
come I will welcome my death even if
it's not quick the world will lie still
again on Monday and it will thank us for
it
additional notes found near the Bonnie
of Reverend harsh or the first of these
appear to be a transcript from a speech
made by the Reverend presumably to the
members of the victory Society brothers
and sisters we come together for the
last time today it has been an honor to
work with you all I could not have hoped
for a better group with which to secure
the future of mankind from the dawn of
time
terrible impossibilities have spawned
for the darkness between stars not
hating life simply being indifferent to
it we are ants to these abominations
these demented gods I use this term as
this is what they are called in older
texts you will not find any biblical God
here or perhaps you will I do not know
the use of God's here is the specific
form of creature born from the
primordial chaos of this reality not
just a powerful be simply powerful
beings do not reach the uncaring depths
of cruelty and depravity that the gods
do they are so far above us that we are
but incensed accordingly
we shall look as such in order to gain
the forgiveness and the favor of the
gods we must learn to know our place
before them
each of these things seeks dominion over
the laws of reality itself imposing the
nature of their twisted existences upon
stars and planets and people the only
answer to this threat these gods must be
destroyed the slate wiped clean we could
not do this
by no means
no but we cannot allow these things to
exist a kingdom cannot have a billion
kings we cannot kill gods no only a god
and kill a god we will bring them here
and bind them bind them until their
bloodlust is sated until all but one is
dead always a single God remains the
victor who returns whence they came as
the only god remaining but their
primordial chaos eventually spawns more
guns more twisted angels and demons and
so it all comes to pass again our
vigilance must be constant for a new
victor must be found again and again we
will leave a mark in creation but it
will fade it will heal stands strong as
our people have before stand strong as
the near Men in ancient cities did it
stands strong as we did at the gates of
Sodom stand strong as we have always
stood strong because this must always be
done fortune favors those who take bold
steps we shall become unified with an
animator and during the somnium eternal
may we be forgiven sorry I seem to have
hamd that speech up a little bit whilst
delivering it it was purely for dramatic
effect I like to make these lectures
more entertaining for you all moving on
the following section was found in the
back cover of ha shores journal
and the victor shall walk away from the
roubles of man and bestow clarity glory
and majesty to those who remain from the
red of my eyes I see them yes I do
yes I do and they see me I do all of it
right and this is my repayment I do not
fear the roubles of man
they are our glory hour hour I don't
know what they are I don't know what I
am my throat goes somewhere else my
throat goes somewhere else and I do not
like where it goes in a war there is
fire but here the fire is cold and
sideways and in the atoms themselves in
the minds even because my head ache like
a nut that is cracking because of the
baby bird inside it I must clean my
wounds but my hands are made of wire and
cyanide I can see them towering and they
are nothing they are the shadow of the
tip of a finger nails finger nail no no
no no no no no no no to quell the Titans
for fire ice and lightning we must eat
babies and live happily ever after
it's not right they're meant to be dead
now the victor shall walk from the
rubbles of man and others shall walk
behind him video recovered from a camera
found on a rooftop during an expedition
near a church in the centre of Dale port
several entities of varying descriptions
are visible engaging in hostilities with
each other
Dail ports church is visible in the
background as the density of SCP 1936 -
one is reduced for unknown reasons a
large creature of irregular shape which
appears to be composed of large
quantities of stone soil and what is
thought to be some form of fungi appears
several metres above the church camera
began shaking at this time a sound akin
to a distorted whale song is audible
the creature is estimated to be 50
meters in height a second entity
manifests above the church the entity
has a crystalline structure and a bright
light is emanating from its central
spire a 15 second long screech is
audible already manifested entities
cease hostilities and quickly leave the
area in a manner that suggests that they
are fleeing what is presumed to be a
third entity manifests the camera
distortion prevents an analysis of its
appearance a deep humming noise is
audible for the duration of the footage
until it cuts out okay who'd have
thought Cthulhu liked mythos was real
huh well that about does it for today
thank you all for listening and you were
all dismissed goodbye
[Music]
I would like to give a special thank you
to Andre best shift
thank you very much Andre your pledge is
very much appreciated if you would like
to know how you can get a personalized
thank e at the end of each of my videos
as well as some other really cool stuff
as well go to patreon.com/scishow
[Music]
[Music]
you